[Music]
on this Friday night escaping erupting
infernos wildfires spark a critical
situation in BC and the Northwest
Territories people were crying we may
have another scary night tonight and
it's going to look worse than you ever
expected the homes lost the tens of
thousands of people ordered out before
it's too late The Exodus from
Yellowknife and the exploding flames in
Kelowna our reporters are on the ground
as evacuees seek shelter and Helping
Hands the Canadians doing what Canadians
do best you get your snack in your water
safe travels
global national with para Nasser
good evening and thanks for joining us
we have special coverage tonight if the
fast-moving and unpredictable wildfires
that are ravaging two parts of our
country tonight
Canadians from British Columbia's
Okanagan area and the Northwest
Territories United by fear and
uncertainty this evening worrying
waiting and watching Flames threaten
their homes and their livelihoods this
has been a Canadian Wildfire season
unlike any other and these next 24 hours
are expected to be the most challenging
yet
the situation in both areas is changing
by the minute we'll have more in the
Exodus from Yellowknife shortly but
first residents of Kelowna are no
strangers to wildfires but even seasoned
fire officials say this is unlike
anything they've ever experienced in 24
hours the McDougall Creek Wildfire
exploded in size growing to more than 68
square kilometers a significant number
of homes destroyed overnight thousands
of people are under evacuation orders
one firefighter described his experience
on the ground as 100 Years of
firefighting in one night and crews are
bracing for more
we're going to prepare that it will be
worse and we ask the public to do the
same don't panic
be ready
we may have another scary night tonight
people are going to see that glow again
and it's going to look worse than you
ever expected
and that's describing just one of the
many blazes burning in BC Jules Knox is
in West Kelowna Outside the Fire Command
Center there Jules what's the situation
right now
for our tactical evacuations are being
carried out as we speak authorities are
going door to door telling more and more
people that they need to leave their
homes now to give you an idea of the
size of Kelowna and the surrounding area
it's about 200 000 people
the fire spread from West Kelowna across
the lake to parts of Kelowna last night
and today it's been pushing North into
neighboring Lake Country 2400 properties
are on evacuation order in those three
communities with another 4 800 on
evacuation alert the fire chief says
last night was his worst nightmare at
one point emergency responders were
trapped because they were rescuing
evacuees who hadn't left their homes
some people had to be rescued from the
water because they jumped into the lake
to escape the flames
now there's no confirmed loss of life at
this point but many homes have burned to
the ground the historic Lake Okanagan
Resort has been destroyed officials
haven't yet confirmed how many homes are
lost but evacuees know their
neighborhoods will never be the same
there's a hundred homes in Traders Cove
and
I just can't imagine I understand that
my house is standing
and I don't know why
how can a little pocket of homes be okay
and then the rest of the community
incinerated
so difficult for the people there how is
everyone preparing Jules
well it's very Grim it's alarming the
airport has canceled flights um so that
the firefighting efforts aren't
disrupted as they're trying to tackle
this Blaze the university has been
evacuated it they're expecting worse
conditions as we go into tonight here
and every at many communities throughout
BC
all right Jules Knox in West Kelowna
thank you for your coverage Jules now
the Okanagan fire was just 64 hectares
early this morning but as I mentioned it
exploded in size over the span of 24
hours it's actually now over 100 times
larger than it was and here's a look at
how things quickly spiraled out of
control
the spectacular beauty of Kelowna
captured for a brief moment before the
weather took a turn
the winds just picked up probably the
last 20 minutes it's very concerning as
the afternoon progressed the fire
Advanced steadily closer it's really all
about the ongoing strong winds and uh
the lack of moisture is really what's
helping Drive these fires we knew today
was going to be challenging all the
predictions we expected came true
as night fell the landscape became more
hellish trees candling home after home
up in flames it's all very unreal as
people on the safe side at the Okanagan
Lake in Kelowna watched in horror not
knowing what would come next
and it's 150 feet from me around 9 30 PM
Embers made the two and a half kilometer
jump sparking spot fires just north of
Kelowna it was kind of at a distance
across the lake but now it's
right there
today as daylight reveals some of the
devastation fire Crews remain locked in
a fight the firefight going on right now
is as significant today as it was last
night knowing the danger to this Valley
of paradise is far from over
and Kelowna is far from alone of more
than 380 active wildfires in British
Columbia more than 160 are out of
control still and more than a dozen are
considered either highly visible or a
threat to a community
the kookabee creek Wildfire south of
Litton claimed a historic Fraser Cranium
Landmark on Thursday engulfing a 103
year old Lookout within just minutes
it's also placed the village of Linton
under an evacuation alert shutting down
part of the trans-canada highway just
two years after a massive Wildfire
devastated the community further south a
wildfire west of caramios has grown it
now covers some 220 square kilometers
with dozens of properties under
evacuation orders to the north
evacuations are underway near Kamloops
or the Lower East Adams Lake Fire is
continuing to spread despite suppression
efforts
Global News meteorologist Christy Gordon
joins us now with a look at what's ahead
for BC Christy what does the next 24
hours look like
well the winds in the area have been
Relentless throughout the day the cold
front though finally pushed through the
region today but in behind a cold front
is somewhat times where we get the
strongest Northwest flow and that's what
they've been experiencing gusts ranging
from 30 to 50 kilometers an hour and
it's right during the afternoon evening
hours where the relative humidity is
very low and that means that the fire
movement and behavior can be very
aggressive with it being so dry and
windy here's a look so a Northwest flow
for the the West Kelowna area means that
it pushes the fire more towards
structures and the highway now as we
head through the late evening and
overnight hours we are going to see the
winds come down a little bit and move to
be more of a Northerly flow across the
region so hopefully that's some good
news for the area and when we pull out
and look at the larger picture it's a
very similar plan for all fires across
the southern portions of the province
where a strong Northwest flow will
continue this evening before easing
overnight however looking into tomorrow
although we are going to see it light
overnight the winds that is we are
expecting it to pick up once again
tomorrow afternoon back to you okay
Chrissy thank you for that now we're
gonna have more from BC in just a moment
but we want to turn now to the Wildfire
emergency that's been gripping the
Northwest Territories the deadline is
passed for all 22 000 residents off
Yellowknife to leave that's 40 percent
of the territory's total population
the capital city well it looks more like
a ghost town the large Wildfire burning
West if Yellowknife is getting closer
and residents from there have gone to BC
Alberta and tonight we're hearing
Manitoba as well there's only one
two-lane Highway out of Yellowknife and
the first stop for many evacuees is Fort
Providence that's about three and a half
hours drive where an evacuation shelter
has been set up as well as hotels
tonight the prime minister is expected
to be in Edmonton to visit some evacuees
that have been forced from their homes
our Jamie Dahl was in Yellowknife today
she was talking to some of the last
people in the city before she as well
hit the road to Fort Providence like so
many others
well we are at the airport in the final
moments before everyone has been
requested urged to leave the city of
Yellowknife a lot of people spent the
morning shivering in the cold still
waiting in that registration line trying
to secure a seat on a charter plane out
of here the territory says it will
continue to fly planes out of this
Capital northern city with residents on
board for as long as it possibly can
even into the weekend if needed it has
been an exhausting ordeal for so many
people trying to navigate this crisis
with their children and their pets and
their belongings in tow I'm glad to be
out of here you know
smoke all over yesterday we were there
for eight hours in the line and then we
were told to go home
and today also we have been here since 5
30 a.m in the morning it's very
complicated situation I'd rather be home
fighting with everybody with a fire and
being volunteering and stuff but my
children need me this small Airport
operating double the amount of flights
than it normally does going 24 7 and
it's doing it with the skeleton staff
employees have been acting as security
guards baggage handlers the heaviness
undeniable
you know a lot of
a lot of them have uh you know sent for
families ahead
or got them all came back
so there's a lot of dedication and uh
it's it's amazing these guys are
sticking around an elephant with the
effort to get folks out
as people flee Crews fight setting up
sprinklers on the perimeter
the home team at Buffalo Airways running
water bombers with every chance it can
get and supporting Crews on the ground
just keeping a steady a steady flow of
of support equipment for the guys on the
ground here there are people refusing to
leave but the majority of this northern
city now sits quiet as we ourselves
evacuate
closed captioning not available
the first place to stop is Fort
Providence we find campers hunkered down
there's a gas station it's close enough
that things did turn around we could go
back and if we needed to wait for
everybody else to go by we could let
them all do their thing we can camp here
I've got gas and water and food for
about a week and a half two weeks still
so so we're doing good here until we
hear
a little bit more about what's going on
in Yellowknife and then we'll decide
whether we continue south or whether we
stay here and wait it out a quiet moment
after a stressful week taking a breather
waiting for word from home
Jamie Dahl Global News Fort Providence
four hours further south across the
border in Alberta droves of evacuees
from Yellowknife are stopping over in
the town of high level where much needed
supplies and an evacuation Center has
been set up and that's where we find our
Jeff Semple tonight in high level
Alberta Jeff
hi pharah that's right we're in high
level about 700 kilometers south of
Yellowknife and this has become one of
the main evacuation hubs for those
fleeing the wildfires in the Northwest
Territories it's a small town of about 4
000 people but that population has more
than doubled seemingly overnight as
people have been flooding in here this
curling rink behind me has now been
repurposed with more than 200 cots for
people to sleep they're handing out food
and clothing inside others have been
allowed to bring their RVs here as you
can see and park wherever they want
there are tents set up all throughout
this part this town where people can
camp wherever they want and we've seen
ordinary people opening up their homes
to provide lodging for complete
strangers and one of those recipients of
that generosity in this small community
is Tana Brown who fled her home in
Yellowknife where you were born and
raised hi Tana so I understand you made
the journey here arrived yesterday what
was that Journey like for you
absolutely
some raised just had to pick up and go
with my dog and going through you know
the smoke and seeing the Embers along
the side
blue skies sometimes but then smoke came
back and
driving away leaving my house
it was
like just incredibly surreal and
unbelievable but you had to just go and
not worry about it and and hope for the
best yeah and people like Tana staying
incredibly strong here and unbelievably
difficult circumstances and are being
welcomed with open arms by this
community it's a practiced hand at this
this this community has housed people
almost 20 times over the last 20 years
seven of those times coming just this
year pharah
generosity there thank you so much Jeff
Semple and high level Alberta tonight
coming up our continuing coverage of the
aggressive Wildfire situation in BC and
after the break I'm going to speak with
West kelowna's fire chief who just
recently saw the Blaze from above
the Wildfire situation in BC's Okanagan
Valley continues to develop last night
it spread from West Kelowna to Kelowna
and then today it pushed North into Lake
Country joining us now is West Kelowna
fire chief Jason broland Jason thanks
for joining us you surveyed the damage
from the air recently what did you see
it was uh awe-inspiring
um to see a fire behave the way that it
did and then to see it from above
but to see the loss was gut wrenching
um you know we our hearts go out to the
people who are affected
um and we we are doing our best to try
and let people know but unfortunately
we're still fighting this fire and our
resources are dedicated there you
mentioned that some firefighters were
trapped last night helping people who
didn't want to get out talk to us about
what happened
[Music]
we had issued an evacuation alert early
in the day which is US warning people
that they may need to leave and they may
need to leave on short notice and when
that evacuation alert turned to an
evacuation order we expected that they
would leave but in some cases people
didn't in most cases it was an orderly
evacuation but in some cases some people
didn't until it was too late and they
found themselves trapped after fire had
burned across the roadway and it
required the efforts of the BC Wildfire
service and the RCMP to pull these
people to safety driving through the
flames in order to get them out that's
my worst nightmare to hear that people
are trapped behind a wall of flames and
we you know we definitely went to work
and it must be your biggest worry for
tonight as well you said tonight's going
to be scarier paint a picture what are
you expecting how are you preparing
yeah we are hard at it uh ever since
this morning uh we were dug in fighting
fires in neighborhoods in people's
backyards uh saving their homes because
of a well-placed drop from a helicopter
provided by the BC Wildfire service or
from firefighters being in the right
place at the right time and putting out
an Amber on a roof tonight's going to be
more of the same house to house door to
door firefighting driven by the wind and
the success relies on the hard work of
all of the firefighters on the ground
Chief Jason broland we are with you
we're thinking about you and rooting for
you and your team thank you
still ahead I speak with former Chief of
the defense staff Tom Lawson about the
challenges of yellowknife's wildfire
evacuation
[Music]
back to our continuing coverage of the
erupting Wildfire emergency in
Yellowknife the entire population of the
capital of the Northwest Territories 22
000 people has been ordered out by Road
or by air and I'm joined now by the
former Chief of the defense staff Tom
Lawson General thanks so much for
joining us and giving us your expertise
especially on a day like today can you
first tell me about the complexity of
organizing an operation like this
right so there are a lot of moving parts
of course and the problem often is that
the agencies involved wouldn't have
worked directly together uh what we have
uh going in our favor uh is that similar
operations have happened across Canada
in recent years Fort McMurray Calgary uh
and the lessons were drawn from that
that I'm sure the premier and the other
civilian organizations that will be
working with the Canadian Armed Forces
have learned from uh and taken the
lessons from the pain points come when
those aircraft land for the short amount
of time that they'll be in Illinois are
the people there that are expected to
come out are they all on time uh they
got everything required to get out and
and there will be hitches with that I'm
sure I understand you have a personal
connection to this can you tell us about
it
well my son is one of the Hercules
Pilots so uh very proud that he's a part
of this operation to get Canadians
safely out at Yellowknife I know that he
and his mates from eight wing and those
from Edmonton and General Life uh
although they are normally training for
other uh missions uh International
missions and uh and training uh to do
these kind of things under combat
conditions uh keeping Canadians safe is
job one and I know they're all extremely
proud to be part of this and to get
those uh people who are right now under
threat in Yellowknife two safety uh
further south and I'm sure you're a very
proud dad today as well uh retired
General Tom Lawson thanks so much for
your time and your expertise
pleasure thank you for having me next
how strangers are stepping up helping
animals impacted by the wildfires
as thousands Flee for safety the need
for shelter food and fuel is great and
it's not just people that are in need
Heather York's West has more on the
volunteers that have put their own lives
on hold in order to help their neighbors
to the north
[Applause]
a moment of celebration after a near
Sleepless 24 hours the point was to get
those horses out of there that's all we
that's all I cared about that's all
everybody who's volunteered to help me
when I made the call by Wednesday
morning the group of central Alberta
residents knew the North Country stables
near Yellowknife was in trouble just 16
kilometers from the fire and without
enough trailers to move all the animals
to safety helpers hit the road
each other and then the chaos sets it
after loading 22 horses five goats and
an assortment of other animals the team
joined the thousands of drivers on
Highway 3 heading out but along the way
they found other helpers too do you like
some water yeah
a more than three hour drive from
Yellowknife Fort Providence is the only
fuel stop for hours as evacuees wait
volunteers have been delivering food and
other supplies some people were crying
because they were so thankful that
somebody's here
I guess that's what it is you know but
we just want to help well it's good you
know that means the community to come
together as one irregardless of what
happens you know we're there for each
other
and that's important
there's more help head Ed their way
we're loading up our trucks and we're
heading north this Salvation Army team
from Edmonton bringing badly needed
support to the First Responders in
Yellowknife who've stayed behind because
with more difficult days to come the
helpers need help too Heather your ex
West Global News
and that's global national for this
Friday night I'm far enough sir and we
leave you tonight with more scenes from
the wildfires in BC's Okanagan area and
the Northwest Territories for those of
you watching us who have been impacted
by the wildfires your and our thoughts
take good care of yourselves and take
care of each other good night
foreign
[Music]